we just did the press junket for jackass
forever and um
it it like it seems like we did hundreds
of interviews and it seemed also that
a lot of the the questions from the
interviewers were like so this you know
this is it the swan song it's over
yeah and and i and i said well actually
after each and every one of the first
three jackass movies knoxville declared
on the record that it was over and this
fourth movie is actually the first time
he hasn't declared that i keep saying
like we may we might we might not but
there's no like
definitive answer but i think these
reporters have to come in with some
angle right right so it's whatever i
understand i think what they're what
they're
interpreting
is uh
you're saying that you're done risking
your life you can't get and get in there
with bulls anymore this is the last
movie that you're really going to risk
your life for right right and thank god
because i don't want you to
i don't
i never wanted to see you with the bull
in the first place i definitely never
want to see you with another bull again
and if anybody reacts to your saying
that it you know in any kind of a
critical way let me put it out there
that it was on
the third movie i showed up and i said
dude i'm not gonna risk my life i've
survived enough you know i've made it
this far i've lost my [ __ ] sense of
humor for being in a wheelchair or a
coffin right over a dumb ass [ __ ]
jackass
i'm not doing it and i pretty much stuck
to my guns i said i said if uh if if
it's a risk of
paralysis or death i'm not doing it but
if there's not that risk then i'm in and
i don't think i backed out of anything
yeah no you i mean
if you didn't say that i don't think
anyone would realize it because you've
performed so great in jackass three and
forever so well thanks man now i i
showed up with the same rules on
jackass forever and one weekend i i
called it that the treadmill stunt was
uh a real problem for for the spine and
the brain for everybody
yeah dude